do you carry around one phone for work
and another phone for personal use do
you wish you could just carry one the
desire to have one device for both work
and personal use is a common one but
often due to very valid reasons like
security it isn't possible for many
people with Android for work IT
management can set up your personal
device for secure use at work while you
maintain control of your device and your
personal information I'm Jean tranqs and
I'm going to run through our solution
for using Android devices for both work
and play Android has evolved to add
secure management of data and apps that
can be consistently applied across
devices be it the traditional premium
devices used today in many companies or
the lower-cost high volume devices used
by over a billion people around the
world or the many single-use corporate
or kiosk type applications all of these
variations can be work in abled and best
of all they remain easy to use by the
end-user introduced in early 2015
android for work brings the best
features of Android to the enterprise
including our focus on Android
innovation our great device ecosystem
app development and device management
capabilities android for work comprises
features in two areas enhancements to
the Android device experience and new
tools for our partners to add value in
the enterprise devices get enhancements
to Android and lollipop and newer to
support work profiles an app that allows
for the same user experience on older
devices Google Play for work for
securely distributing apps and built-in
productivity tools to make sure everyone
has a consistent user experience no
matter what device they choose for our
partners the main features are new
interfaces for enterprise mobility
management partners to control and
administer every aspect of this
enterprise experience new interfaces for
app developers that allow EMM partners
to remotely configure enterprise apps
for end-users and of course Android
remains an open platform where our
device partners can continue to innovate
and add additional features let's take a
little deeper into what's new and
Android for work devices as we mentioned
earlier android for work in lollipop
which is android 5
Oh introduces the concept of work
profiles the ability to securely
separate work data from personal data
and allow the enterprise to control only
the work profile this allows you to
still maintain your privacy on the
device that you bring into work known as
BYOD built right into Android this data
separation is achieved through a
combination of full device encryption
coupled with multi-user support picture
a work user and a personal user running
simultaneously on one device in addition
to separating data on the device it also
allows IT admins to control which apps
can communicate with each other and
allows for the optional obfuscation of
notifications to protect company data
when your device is locked and you
receive a new work email for example for
the end user the experience is seamless
work apps live alongside personal apps
and are denoted by the Android for work
briefcase badge and our EMM partners
have integrated all these capabilities
into the mobile device management
consoles that your IT department is
using today for devices that are not
running Android version 5.0 or newer and
some lollipop devices that don't support
profiles we've provided the Android for
work app it offers backwards
compatibility going back to Android
version 4.0 Ice Cream Sandwich this app
can be downloaded from the Play Store
and uses container technology to provide
a very similar user experience as those
newer devices things like badged work
apps separation of data restriction of
intents which is data sharing across
apps and it allows management through
that same console that your IT
department is already using one of the
most important features of android for
work is its use of Google Play for work
as the method for distributing and
managing applications for the work
profile enterprise's can choose any app
free or paid from the Google Play Store
and white listed for optional
installation into the work profile they
can also silently push apps into the
work profile while purchasing is now
supported for paid apps and custom apps
can also be deployed utilizing a private
channel on Google Play for restricted
access to only users in your
organization the Android for work apps
ports a more limited set of apps from
the Google Play Store but the experience
is the same whitelisting apps and
deploying them via Google Play it's
important to note that only apps that
have been approved ahead of time and
whitelisted by IT can be installed into
the work profile and they must come from
the Google Play Store so there's no risk
of any unapproved apps and again all
this is controlled by your EMM via
policy through the management tools that
you use today all this control applies
to the work profile or the android for
work app if it's a BYOD device the user
can still use their own apps on the
personal side and the data never gets
combined and if it's a BYOD device the
company can't wipe your personal data to
make the user experience consistent
across all different devices on
different OS versions from different
manufacturers android for work provides
a full suite of optional productivity
tools there's a pim suite email contacts
calendar tasks that supports exchange
and Lotus Notes via active sync with
advanced enterprise features like s/mime
encrypted email and free/busy lookup
Docs sheets and slides are provided for
the editing of email attachments these
work in office compatibility mode and
provide the ability to edit and save and
attach to emails there's a PDF viewer
and chrome is provided as the browser
Google Apps users would use Gmail
instead of the PIM suite but they also
get access to the additional online
collaborative features of Docs sheets
and slides all of these apps can be
configured remotely by the enterprise to
reduce complexity for the end user
for example pre-populating server
settings or proxies or bookmarks in
Chrome etc in fact any ISV can make use
of these new remote configuration
capabilities to make their apps easier
to deploy in the enterprise - we've
talked a bit about some of the new
features in Android for work and the
end-user experience but it's critical to
note that there's a lot more going on
behind the scenes and we rely on our
partner ecosystem to put the whole
package together on the devices side
we've built these new features into the
Android platform and have worked closely
with the device OMS to implement them in
devices running lollipop and newer
versions of Android on the applications
for
and we've discussed new capabilities in
remote management that our ISV partners
are adopting and there's also new VPN
capabilities in android for work that
allow for either per profile or per app
VPN all of these new capabilities rely
on the EMM partners that have utilized
the Android for work ap is to build in
the capabilities to manage the work
profile android for work app app
configuration and per app VPN all from
that single management console so just
to review we've talked a little bit
about the end user features and the
features that are important to IT and
how you can use your device for both
work and personal use thank you for your
time and I hope you've learned some more
about Android for work and the
capabilities that will make it easier to
manage and secure corporate data on
Android devices while still allowing you
to maintain control of your device and
protect your privacy
you